- Great movies have been
made out of mediocre scripts
and not great movies have been
made out of great scripts.
If you have any wisdom
whatsoever, you know to follow,
you know, wherever there is great energy.
Adulthood is about compromising.
It's all about compromising
and how much you compromise
before you compromise yourself.
You have to work hard,
like freedom is one the
other side of discipline.
- He's an American actor
who began acting as a child
with his film debut in
City Slickers in 1991.
His breakout role was in the
cult movie hit, Donnie Darko.
For Nightcrawler, his
performance was widely acclaimed
and won great rave reviews from critics.
He's Jake Gyllenhaal, and here's my take
on his top ten rules for success.
Rules number one is my personal favorite,
and make sure to stick
around all the way to the end
for some special bonus clips,
and if there's something that Jake says
that really inspires
you as you're watching,
make sure to leave it in
the comments with quotes
so other people can benefit as well.
(whooshing)
- Someone said to me once
that like a, and I know that
my mother being a screenwriter,
she's not going to agree with me on this,
but that, you know, great
movies have been made
out of mediocre scripts,
and not great movies
have been made out of
great scripts, you know?
There is something in that process,
'cause there is a general
kind of philosophy
that you need a great
script, which I agree with.
I totally agree with, but ultimately,
I think you need an energy.
You need a drive and a
belief in what you're doing,
and that belief, whatever that is,
can change an entire
film.
It can change anything, really.
What I was always taught as a kid was
to try and listen to myself
and to trust certain instincts, you know?
To listen to people around
me and to use those instincts
to try and guide me, you know?
And I think, you know,
you get, you're on
course, you're off course,
you move around, you're all different,
you try this path, you try
that path, whatever it is,
but I think I've just
become much clearer about
my instinct,
and particularly my initial instincts.
I'm not talking about like oh,
that person seems like a nice...
I'm talking about the
instinct when we talk about
reading the script for this movie,
and I all of a sudden
thought this guy is a coyote.
It came to my mind, and I
thought he needs to be hungry.
You know, things work in the
moment and then can die off,
and then things can not work
in one moment and come to life,
and if you have any wisdom whatsoever,
you know to follow, you know,
wherever there is great energy,
and that's what I followed
with Denis when we did Enemy.
I went this guy has great energy.
We vibe on each other,
and I got to go with this.
Like I don't know what this movie's about,
but I know this energy.
- [George] Right.
- And I know this energy
is success somewhere,
creative success, and that's
first and foremost to me,
and that's what I follow now,
and that energy drives a movie.
When you watch it as an
audience, it's infectious.
When you see that on the screen,
and I see it all the time with people,
you're infected by that energy.
I think I just decided
should try not to compromise,
you know, certain things.
You know, one of these things,
and it's funny to bring up,
my publicist, because she
was the one who recommended
this documentary to me,
but in this documentary
that I watched a few
years ago, The Promise,
the one about Bruce Springsteen,
you know, he said that
adulthood is about compromising.
It's all about compromise
and how much you compromise
before you compromise yourself,
and I think that when I
say there is no compromise
in the choices I made, I don't
know if that's totally true,
but I think it was sort of
not compromising myself,
you know, and trying to be as
mindful in decisions I
was making as possible,
not only in the movies,
but also within scenes and everything.
- [David] The weird thing
about becoming a movie star,
it just kind of happened.
What about yourself?
- Strangely, it does sort of happen,
like in your 20s, which
is when a majority of
all that stuff started to
happen was I think you just
sort of, you do the best you can.
Listen to yourself, but you also
follow different people's leads
and try and learn from it,
so I mean, that sort
of ended up happening,
and I sort of hit 30 and
I was like wait a second.
I want to get back on stage again
and do this thing that
I love doing so much,
and it just happened.
- [David] Well, all of your
choices lately, actually,
as for film as well, I mean,
are we in a post-ab phase
of Jake Gyllenhaal's career?
Is that?
- Aptly put, or should I say ab-tly put.
I think,
yes and no.
I mean, I don't know.
Yeah, I guess if it's about,
to me, if it ends up being about vanity
or something like that, then
it's just the wrong direction,
you know, and I think
ultimately if it's about
what you feel and what moves you
and what roles you want to play
or what people you want to work with.
If those are the choices
and that's how it's done,
then I think, you know,
that's what fulfills me,
so whether it's post or not,
I think I always was doing that, you know?
My intention always, whenever
I go into any creative
sort of environment or experience, is to
give my all, you know?
I mean, I care a lot, you know?
And it always has been like that.
So let me just say, the one thing I do
really, really know now
is how blessed I am to be
working in this business,
and that you have to work hard.
Like freedom is on the
other side of discipline,
and when somebody says I want you to play
this role in my movie, you
have a great responsibility,
and it's just bottom line for me.
And from here on out,
and has been for a while,
that is I will do
everything I can for that,
so as long as the opportunities come,
I will do my best and try my best
to do the best that I
can do at that moment.
- Do you care about the
business end of things
when you pick gigs now?
In terms of this what seems
to be a highly curatorial
approach to what you do,
does it matter if your
agent goes hey, man,
you really should do
this role in Iron Man,
because it's going to
be big business for you?
- If my agent did that, we
wouldn't be working together.
- Really?
- Yeah, because I think that,
you know, to me, we're not talking about.
We're talking about, you know,
I mean, I'm incredibly blessed, you know,
in the work that I do in
terms of that kind of stuff.
I mean, that's just not the discussion
that I want to be having.
You know?
That's just, at this point in my life,
I believe that
I want to stay true to a certain instinct.
Now, that instinct changes
at times, you know?
And it will change over the course of,
hopefully, I get to work more, you know?
And hopefully I'll be
making different choices
and I might come in
here two years from now
and have a different
approach, but I do know that
it should always be about
something that's coming
from something I believe in,
'cause that's all that I can bring.
You know, it's really
all that I can bring,
and it's going to satisfy some people
and it's not going to others,
just as things other people do satisfy me
and some people don't, you know?
But if we have that discussion,
to me, I just,
you know, it's not one I
necessarily want to have.
To me, it's become much more about craft,
and I think, actually, on a smaller scale,
I think it's possibly to do
it on a really big scale,
but I think that, on a smaller scale,
I think preparation is key.
That I kind of went back to
deciding or sort of choosing
preparation over everything
and the amount of time it takes
when you have a lot less
money to use, you know,
and you have to make
choices very specifically,
and they have to be kind of
prepared much earlier on,
so that you're free in, you know,
a very small period of space.
You have a lot more freedom
because of all the preparation
that you've done.
I mean, just in terms of
the process of acting,
that's what I
started to learn when I did End of Watch,
this movie with David Ayer.
You know, I spent five
months with police officers,
and that was the beginning of realizing
how much I loved preparation
and how much I loved the
process before the performance,
and I had always loved
that when I was on stage
because there's always that
very formal rehearsal process
that allows you to
explore and use your mind
and go to places that are wrong
as well as places that are right,
and I love being wrong
and right, you know?
And I love people saying hmm,
that idea doesn't really work for this,
you know, and I'm having an
exchange with the director.
I love that.
I love that kind of I'm bringing an idea
and it gets vetoed or it gets accepted.
Whatever it is, it's just
the ability to bring ideas,
and I see that it's much
more possible to do that
within the prep time than it
is in the moment of shooting.
I was thinking about this the other day.
I was thinking about
working with Dustin Hoffman
when I was
20 years old or 23 or something like that,
and I remember Dustin coming up to me
and him saying to me, "You know you don't
"have to do so much," and I was like what?
He said, "You know you carry
everything inside you already.
"Like you could probably just stand there
"and there's enough that
people could watch, you know?"
And that was expressed,
actually, while we were doing
this movie I just did in
a way that I really like,
which is just deliver the pizza, you know?
And that's one of the
biggest things I learned,
which is, you know, we all carry with us
like everything we do,
like everything we've been
through, good, bad, whatever,
and if you can show up and
literally just deliver the pizza,
like you'll be alright.
(laughter)
Because you're not good, like
he said in a calm tone about,
you know, just speaking poetry, you know?
You know, you don't
have to be the butterfly
flying around, you know?
Just say the word butterfly, you know?
Just say it, because
people will take from that
their own experience,
because if you don't give
credit to the audience
and how intelligent they are
and how much they're going
to be asking already,
then you're done, you know?
I have just learned to have
great respect for the audience,
and I love them, and I will
do anything for their minds.
I know that sounds
crazy, but I really will.
- You seem like a pretty ambitious guy.
Now one does as much as you've done
without being an ambitious guy.
Do you, or does Jake
Gyllenhaal, relate at all
to that notion of success at any cost?
Was that drilled into you at some point?
- I don't know.
I mean, consciously speaking, no.
I mean, no,
and I think what I value
as success as I get older
is a lot different than what it was
when I was a lot younger, you know?
- [Jian] What's the difference?
- Well, I mean, I think an
immature view of success,
you know, which I probably
can be still guilty of,
is all of the things that, you know,
that you get the things
you sort of dream of,
you know, money and
more work, and the work that you wanted,
all of those things.
And I think I now value success
as a much different thing.
I think I value it as,
you know, when I see my friends
with their beautiful children
or in a working relationship of any kind
and all those things, to
me, that's real success,
so I mean, I think that, you know,
when I have like a
great day with my family
or a great day with my nieces or whatever,
that's a successful day, you know?
I could come to the Toronto Film Festival
and people could really love,
you know, a film that I made,
and that's successful,
but it's not necessarily
how I would now judge
success of a certain kind.
- Is that because you sowed your oats?
I mean, is it really?
Is it like did you want
Entourage at some point,
and then you got it?
I don't know.
- I don't know about that.
I think I just credit it to my parents,
and you know, hopefully
values that they instill.
(whooshing)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
NoName11 asked me to,
so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me
to profile next, leave
it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
which of the 10 rules
had the biggest impact on you and why,
what change you're going to
make to your business or life
as a result of watching this video?
Leave it in the comments and
I will join in the discussion.
Finally, I wanted to
give a quick shout out
to Alexis Daroussos.
Alexis, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book.
Really means a lot to me.
Thank you for that support.
For those of you watching, you
want a chance at a shout out
in a future video, make sure
to grab a copy of the book
and email in your receipt
so we can keep track.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
Continue to believe or
whatever your one word is,
and I'll see you soon.
(whooshing)
(distant sirens)
- Come on, marry me?
- Okay, how about let
me check my schedule.
I'll get back to you.
- Hold my hand.
I'll be waiting for you.
- [Bartender] Uh-huh.
- What's up, man?
Thought you said you didn't drink?
- What, you think a man
can't pick up a new habit?
What you doing here, man?
Seriously, this is my spot.
- Can I get a water?
- Sure.
- Can I have some water?
- Drink is a solitary sport.
It's a solitary one.
- Man, I'm just trying to connect here.
- I just.
- I just didn't want to go home.
300 square feet of nothing, you know?
- You got plans?
- I don't know what you mean?
- You know what you're going
to do with all this training
that you think you're
so desperately needing?
What you going to do with it?
- I'm going to fight,
and then I'm going to get my kid back.
- Then you going to
end up right back here?
- What are you saying?
- What do you think got you here?
- Some scumbag killed my wife.
- What do you think you did
to be sitting here?
Why did your wife get killed?
- Look, man, all due respect, you know,
I haven't really gotten much sleep, man.
What are you trying to ask me?
- What happened?
- I don't, I just told you what happened.
- What did you do?
- Why do you keep asking me that question?
- What happened?
What happened?
- I just told you what happened.
- Why?
- I can't tell you why.
What do you mean, why?
- Nevermind.
Can't even hear the question.
- What are you laughing at?
What, is this funny to you?
- You can't even like even.
- That's funny to you?
- Whoa, whoa, whoa.
- Piece of shh.
- See that?
That's what, that's why you're here.
That's why you're here.
- It's all good, Tick?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, it is.
(horns blowing)
- It's all good.
- Yo, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
- [Bartender] Hey, man, don't
bring that shh back in here.
- I'm sorry, man, that's it.
If I broke anything.
- No, it's okay.
We don't need it.
- Nobody wants your money.
What do you want, man?
- I never really had any plans, alright?
My wife always made the plans for me,
and my daughter doesn't even
want to see me right now.
(solemn music)
And I feel like I broke her heart.
- Look, kids, man.
She's not a little girl.
She's trying to take care of herself.
She lost her mother, too.
Even if she hates you, you
got to let her hate you
so she can feel better about
it, so she can get better.
This ain't about how you feel.
I mean, you've got to let
her go through her thing
and not think that thing is your thing.
Then you can deal with like that stuff.
Like boxing, whatever you want.
(sighs)
(liquor trickles)
- Well, at least I don't have to worry
about losing you to PSP.
When forensics is finished
with the guy's place,
we're going to deploy the cadaver dogs.
Look, kid, we can't always
save the day, alright?
We're just cops, janitors.
So you lost this one, alright?
Look, you want fulfillment?
You need to find a girl, you know?
Start a family, have some kids.
Just let it go.
(desk clatters)
(keyboard cracks)
(phone rings)
(toy truck clatters)
(cell phone rings)
- Wait.
Yeah?
- [Rich] Hey, it's Rich.
We found something.
(door squeaks)
- You understand that you
have been read your rights
and you're here voluntarily?
- [Louis] That's right, yes.
- And this is being recorded and filmed?
- Yes, from the camera up there,
in wide angle.
- Mm-hmm.
Can you tell me how it is you were
at the China Town Express
tonight and calling 911?
- Of course.
It began earlier in the day.
I was watering my plant.
I looked out my window at my apartment,
the one you visited,
and I saw a dark colored
vehicle with two men inside
parked across the street.
I didn't think anything of it,
otherwise I would have reported it then.
We began our night.
My
employee and myself,
and around approximately 12:38,
I looked at my rear view mirror
and I saw what looked like the same men
in the same vehicle following us.
I made an evasive maneuver, circled back,
and tailed them to the restaurant,
at which point I saw them go inside
and recognized them as the same
men from the home invasion.
- You told me you didn't see the men,
that you didn't get a good look at them.
- Well, it all came back to
me when I saw them going in,
their shapes and their movements,
and then I saw that one of the
men had a gun under his shirt
and so I immediately got
my phone and dialed 911.
- That's your story.
- That's what happened.
That's why I'm sitting here with you.
I think that the men saw my footage
and they tracked me down.
- [Detective] You want
to know what I think?
- Yes, please.
- I think you withheld information.
I think you saw the two
men in the murder house
in Grenada Hills, and you saw the car,
and you sat on it to get
something you could film.
What do you think about that?
- I think that would be a
very unprofessional thing
for me to do in my business.
- It would be murder.
- I can understand why
you're looking into it,
but I didn't do anything like that,
nothing that could be considered wrong.
- You don't fool me for a minute.
- I'm glad.
- I think everything you've said is a lie.
- I wish my partner was here
to back up what happened.
- You left your dead partner.
- Well, the ambulances arrived.
They're trained professionals.
- Yeah, and you seem real
broken up about that.
- No, he died doing what he loved.
- You filmed him dying.
- Hey, that's what I do.
It's my job.
I like to say that if you're seeing me,
you're having the worst day of your life.
(dynamic music)